hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to the game that is
literally the only name of this game :
the game : and here we go
oh okay
oh great
see here's the thing oh that was the
intro for the splash screen oh that poor
guys but I I have not even loaded up
this game because I wanted to get it as
much surprised as possible when I was
doing this in what in the world's
happening and our kisum the game oh that
was not the name the rules of the game
no rules rules just play play
okay thanks anonymous dude I guess I'm a
walking prove that government you kill
yourself just for what oh my god
alright then pantheism the game oh I get
it
oh I'm Albert Einstein I'm assuming
gravity is pleased by human sacrifice
but quantum mechanics hasn't decided oh
it's a Hollow Earth
duh when would I be able to fall that's
the only lead oh you fell all the way
through China
thanks for causing the earth there was
no land there you can't say that I did
anything because it was absolutely
nothing underneath me to hollow
nickle ISM the game this is testing my
big vocabulary my initial ISM
oh all right then the point is it's
pointless hmm no seriously it's a filler
level go back what go back to what
there's no porn if you want I was not
wondering that I was not I swear I was
not wondering that why would I have
wondered that Oh pervert you waited a
flu hit a full 10 seconds what I didn't
wait a full 10 so I was talking to my
audience here trying to defend myself
saying the news no porn and it
definitely wasn't no porn communism the
game aka on your marks get set go oh
okay
all right I'm guessing uh do you think
he's that same thing as I did before
except I do it first sorry you weren't
equal enough more for the risk more for
the rest of us was there another way to
do that was there a way for me to win
that communism to the game Soviet Union
theory is not practice you have been
done personally falling out of political
this game is amazing monogamy the game
getting had two times better than one
literal heartbreak all's fair in love
and war I don't think that was either
love or war that was just the the
awesome animation of two hearts battling
it to the death I guess in a way that is
a perfect analogy for relationships and
everyday and we should all be very
grateful for this scenario to be put in
front of us so we can live right next
level censorship the game sensor
shivering is a game oh hi
so I heard you like the Beijing Olympics
maybe Oh rofl now that's it what I guess
what is this
fatalism the game you're all just NPCs
okay I think we all know it's gonna
happen it is inevitable Esther Anderson
my destiny whatever I'm the one I can
control things with my mind in both
worlds ah rewriting code
well I supposed to just wait here I told
you so mr. Anderson I think we also
predicted some witty one-liner
oh maybe I need to rewatch the matrix
not the matrix shooting lawyers in the
face of the game okay
yes murderer I'm a horrible person I'm
literally shooting flying lawyers who
are a miracle of nature and I'm just
shooting them out of the sky God how
many times if it actually could fly how
soon would it be until he got shot down
like some military mentally my radar mr.
governor president man there general
that's not exactly how that story goes I
hope you enjoyed that story I worked
really hard on maybe this is it's gonna
keep going until I don't shoot him in
the pole
why don't you came-- hey I'm in control
here yeah I didn't get you in the face
but I got you in like the chest region I
don't even need to get close to them I
think my buckshot spray pattern is so
big they kidding oh you thought you
could dodge me huh
I didn't even get a chance to dodge
there maybe wasn't gonna dodge maybe was
coming out guys do that I'm a mass
murderer I take away give them nothing
but I take from them everything how one
go I have fun is that a Dick Cheney joke
is that Dick Cheney being killed by
Sarah Palin today mooses coming soon
Putin that's Putin the Vice in vice
president don't laugh she's watching you
Putin from her backyard yep that's about
Sarah Palin warf domestic spying the
game big brother is watching you too
Tom's my big brother if you have nothing
to okay let's see what what oh okay I
didn't know this game was gonna take
such a political stance happening
alcoholism game oh no no no one will be
the bog click the drunk bastard to start
Am I am I trying to never oh wait so
this is a difficult actually have to
move myself all that much I'm gonna
watch the straight light anyway by this
great this teaching kids great thing you
get drunken if you can get away with it
enough you [ __ ] don't drink and drive
don't drink and drive don't drink and
drive don't drink and dive wait god damn
it
alright give me I can imagine some about
Spartans in there the five saves the
game hi I bet we're gonna be best of
friends I don't know what are you
talking about see one thing I can do
good jump I guess please don't kill me
press an old space and I'll dance for
you wow you do dance
that's incredible you're really good at
that okay time to die oh that's the
point okay it's okay with it
it's totally fine your problems are gone
unfortunately so are you well that was
sad let's just move on abstinence only
the game
no pain no game the rules of the game
don't do anything okay
I knew good good I'm enjoying this I'm
having fun well oh is this where I am in
LA
Joey in Cincinnati it's snowing a lot of
the Northeast really bad too bad stuff
oh [ __ ] oh I got an STD on my copy no no
okay please no you're so totally screwed
like if you want to go that way
Trojan virus Trojan condoms always use
norton antivirus protection ah
advertisement sponsored by Norton yeah
while you had to get aboard please
oh god this is so horrible to bet the
game okay it depends on what your Deveny
oh man Tibet is logged out of China this
wall right then Free Tibet surf the
internet how the hell did you get past
the Chinese Internet censors
you know what oh you know this is
America feminism cochise lady ah what
should I choose who should I offend oh
why is this power left into my hands I
guess I could see oh not only are they
literally damned
Oh
well the road to hell is paved with
screwed intentions guys next time you
get the damn gross what's going on oh
we're offending everybody all right oh
yeah yeah global warming the game
okay inconvenience poof what am I Elvis
or am i I'm Al Gore okay you can
obviously tell if this game originates
from new grounds just because it's
completely ridiculous no one is free
from peeing made fun of and goddamn it's
just that right flavor of offensive all
across the board red tape deck boy
that's a pun no - okay good okay never
mind I just got a checkpoint then what
is that let me fall off of it okay all
right then it's not a very solid piece
of clown I'm guessing unless Caesar like
snow oh it's okay then I guess okay yeah
you do some
yeah it's what I saw yeah it's what I
thought
[ __ ] you know the checkpoint I'm awfully
close to the edge here I don't want to
get too close to these Gore mansion oh
great good thing he has a giant sign
like that Thank You Al Gore EO but your
politics are in another castle Alec and
read this at least you got Internet he's
like the same jokes god this game came
out and o8 like all these jokes were
like inundated in this time period like
my god MC Escher the game to infinity
and beyond and beyond there beyond go
get to the top but how it's an
impossible geometry it can't be done you
won't ever hit bottom to put it in
perspective the honor beyond Devon did I
mention beyond okay good science the
game reductionism has never been so
completed getting down with Galileo hey
there oh oh I can't dance
I'm holding space you want me touching
butts
touching butts touching butts all day
long touching butts touching but we all
love to touch our butts
well dad turn turn Benjamin Franklin
Shockey no no that's not what happened
coming soon large head hurt oh it's
gonna divide by zero' black hole thought
that was a penis at first conclusion you
must be bored as hell help me by getting
signs the game peer-reviewed okey-dokey
conservation is in the game retro gaming
accepted pong spore notice wait what am
I supposed to do when I noticed the
white those white clouds they're awfully
white over there hey I notice you I
noted you get back here you [ __ ] no
change for a change the original
maverick looks like every other
capitalism the game yes putting the sin
in business hello but first a word from
our sponsor wait if that's the word from
our sponsor then that means we're not
doing a joke with Microsoft
me me always me me give me the money you
know me yeah me
now you I'll pay you to get me more
money me me me me I got the top hat I'm
obviously the dignified one me get me
just marry me Oh me me me me me me me me
me me
Wow seven hundred billion tokens to
replay epic ball you can put dipstick on
a pig democracy the game one for all in
most / 102 vote on this Oh Aaron it
looks like you've already voted you have
to wait four years before you vote again
have Mickey Mouse if you think you can
vote in a world goofier than you are
well you're nuts a democracy and if
argumentum and ad populum ain't good
enough for our police were send in the
argumentum ad by column a su l'm Coulomb
putting the maken democracy I wasn't
expecting that a literal Asian fail if
this was DBZ the next ten levels would
just be about info music artists the
game satara's Bob pop vulture oh well
too bad you couldn't see that one
because of that copyrighted music in it
yay Medicare the game
it's himself bourbon man I've been
injured covering recovering gym there
currently five thousand two hundred and
thirty-four people online waiting please
hold
they're currently foul lag what to get
for a free game usin oh that's that's
technically whatever Zoo the whole time
I guess long live the right to die the
game is free word that's why it sucks
yes what you get for free game oh man
alternative medicine the game you also
get a certain alternate ending oh I get
to pick oh I could do pick exorcism
acupuncture New Age magnet therapy
homeopathy homeopathy
I'll choose exorcism okay that worked
great
thanks Jesus you think that's
pacifism the game what if I was on your
side the whole time have a sister what
are you even talking about
okay all right I'd say don't kill his
bud kill this guy's make love not war
zone couch this game okay we're still
rolling my god oh I get to choose I'm
Rick James oh there's another one that I
can't do
I've already way mine
damn it damn it damn it damn it Rick
James I can't beat him
I can't beat him aah oh I couldn't beat
him there's no way for all the game
alright hey hey what's my objective
who's my objective what what am I
supposed to be doing here
okay I'm gonna how do we and wine see a
row man therefore you win oh goody
it's music that you can't hear but I'll
sing it for you when it comes up
oh she's just singing I was gonna start
singing dammit oh go for it
ah dope the game marry Juwanna
cannabliss
420 please yeah that's what you get for
a game sold on the black market because
it's legal which will put you into debt
forcing you to rob and kill making this
game even more illegal in my ratings
going even higher yeah me Taming of the
Shrew game aka play the play now tamer
damn this kinky what what wait tame the
Shrew is it that's like a reference to
something I can remember well the error
of comedies if you want more death Prime
Macbeth Bush administration the game
eight years in the aching it's like the
jokes are funny but they're so outdated
oh man
cuz we're like 2015 years it's like this
was seven years ago
seven years ago
yeah Debbie
W dad change oh wait
cuz retro getting suck so this will be
the last game remake I do supernatural
claims the game take this game seriously
Oh God orbs no there's a millions of
parts
you must be Co sorts run away man there
goes here run away
oh wow all right taking it to a whole
nother level
who are you gonna call Mythbusters okay
now it's the last game remake I do
prisoner's dilemma the game game theory
the game okay
psychic the game
aka no strip dumbass with fills beyond
the grave of reaching to be the energy
is fading but I think they're trying to
send you a message does the letter U
remind you of anything I do not
understand your silence does it remind
you anything yes oh yes tell me more
about it
you are hold on I'm getting a message
from beyond they're telling me you are
oh yeah the monkey will come out of your
ass and you lose $40 oh man I bet James
Randi won't want to replicate that trick
but if you're psychic you knew that
already
war on terror the game the game critics
are oh boy here we go
September oh comedy the game because
they won't publish my semi okay never
well is this the Divine Comedy we're
talking about or is this is normal the
next-to-last supplement what this is the
next-to-last level play
haha
beyond the game game over man game over
it's really are you sure about that it's
been quite an adventure I didn't expect
it to go this long but holy hell we're
here oh that's really it Nikolas Leo Leo
Wow
got a dam that was both hilarious
horribly offensive and gosh darn
inappropriate at times but that's like
what Newgrounds was all about it was all
about like pushing things past the point
where they should have been pushed in
some directions I mean some some
animations some games went way way worse
than this but hey it's a game of its
times and it was highly recommended by
all of you guys and tipo it's not
whether you want to lose it's how you
play the game but in case you're
wondering you lost try again well I
apparently lost I don't have time to go
back and try to win again and just to be
clear there are two other games after
this one this is a trilogy a trilogy so
while it was offensive it didn't have a
lot of moments that made me laugh pretty
hard so I will obviously title this game
offensive in some way or warn you guys
in the beginning that this is for an
open-minded crowd as opposed to just not
an open-minded crowd but it is what it
is this game is what it is and to be
honest I enjoyed it for the most part so
thank you all so much for watching I
really want you guys to let me know if
you want to see the next two parts I
might play them anyway but I do want
your input on this because like hey I
don't know what you guys are gonna think
about this game like a lot of this was
funny to me and you guys might be
offended that I thought some of it was
funny hey this Wiz so thank you all so
much for watching click the annotation
or for any videos that I've done and as
always I will see you